les chefs d'antenne sont prêts pour un
automne qui sera marqué par la campagne
électorale québécoise patrice roy
animera le débat des chefs québec 2022
et la soirée électorale en direct de la
nouvelle maison de radio-canada juste
derrière nous on va faire la soirée dans
l'atrium c'est grandiose en même temps
le pari c'est de pas perdre de vue que
les gens parlent avec les yeux donc ça
va être un mélange de clan rapproché du
monde d'émotions défaite victoire
électorale c'est beaucoup sortent toute
la journée les politiciens vont faire
leurs annonces au téléjournal de ces
deux galipeau au sommaire à de près les
villes baromètre et on diffusera une
série de reportages tournés en région 5
par 5 7 5 en jeu cinq régions cinq
minutes cinq journalistes cinq parties
bon on ainsi simplifier les choses pour
que les gens s'en rappellent mais dans
les faits c'est un peu une couverture
pour un peu voir ce qui se passe
ailleurs le petit peu dans les régions
ont plus des élections les faux de
radio-canada s'intéressera à l'inflation
nous on prépare une émission spéciale
sur l'inflation et la récession de
l'inflation à la récession point
d'interrogation c'est jeudi 25 ou et une
émission spéciale aussi débat économique
avec les principaux candidats des
principaux partis il sera aussi question
au cours des prochains mois de la guerre
en ukraine et de la pandémie l'émission
24,60 va célébrer sa 15e saison dans son
nouveau studio alors je paraphrase de
certains politiciens c'est moi quel plus
beau studio alors évidemment ça permet
une communication extraordinaire parce
que différents plateaux et la pâte au
plateau plus intimes
aux affaires publiques l'émission
découverte va célébrer sa 35e saison la
facture sa 28e saison tandis que pour sa
21e saison l'épicerie accueille une
nouvelle coanimatrice myriam fehmiu
c'est un stimulant celle fans après 20
ans d'avoir du nouveau quelqu'un qui
arrive avec des nouvelles idées une
nouvelle façon de penser avec un bagage
différents télé radio web l'information
à radio-canada est plus que jamais
multiplateforme le public est toujours
là toujours leur présence sur les médias
traditionnels soleil temps c'est
fondamental qu'on soit présent sur les
réseaux sociaux que le laboratoire de
journalisme arad qui continue d'innover
l'automne sera très occupé avec des
cotes d'écouté records l'information de
radio-canada est sur une lancée au grand
bonheur de ses journalistes ça fait du
bien de voir que on est autant d'énergie
dans quelque chose et les gens nous
suivent alors tant mieux qu'on croise
les doigts pour remercie les
téléspectateurs ici tout est fait depuis
mai radio canada montréal